we're asked which value for d we see d
in this equation here makes x equals
negative 3 an extraneous solution for
this radical equation square root of 3x
plus 25 is equal to d plus 2x
encourage you to pause the video and try
to think about it on your own before we
work through it together
all right now let's work through this
together
so the first thing that just remind
ourselves is what is an extraneous
solution well that's a solution that we
get or we think we get but it's really
just a byproduct of how we solved it but
it isn't going to be an actual solution
of our original equation now how do
these extraneous solutions pop up
well it pops up when you when you take
the square of both sides
so for this equation right over here to
get rid of the radical i'd want to
square both sides of it if i square both
sides the left hand side will become 3 x
plus 25 and the right hand side if i
square this is going to be what is going
to be d squared
plus 4
4 dx plus
x squared so that's just squaring both
sides of this but notice you actually
there's actually a different equation
than this one that if you squared both
sides you would also get this what is
that different equation well the
different equation is if you took the
negative of one of these sides so for
example if you had if you started the
original equation the negative square
root of 3x plus 25
plus 25 is equal to d plus 2x you square
both sides of this you still get this
purple equation because you square a
negative you get a positive so both of
them when you square both sides get us
get us over here and so when you solve
this purple equation this is going this
is a quadratic right over here you just
rearrange it a little bit you get into
standard quadratic form you'll get two
solutions and it turns out one of the
solutions is going to be for this yellow
equation and one of the solutions is
going to be for the purple equation
and
if if you the x the one the solution
that is for the purple equation is going
to be an extraneous solution for the
yellow equation it's actually not going
to be a solution for the yellow equation
so when they say which value for d makes
x equals negative 3 an extraneous
solution
for this yellow equation that's the same
thing as saying what value of d makes x
equals negative 3 a solution
for this
so
a
solution
a solution
for this if it's a solution for this
it's going to be an extraneous solution
for that because these are two different
equations we have this is we're taking
the negative of just one side of this
equation to get this one if you took the
negative of both sides of this and that
becomes the same thing because you could
multiply both sides of an equation times
a negative value so a solution for this
which is equivalently a solution which
is equivalent to the solution if i
instead of putting the negative on the
left hand side if i multiply the right
hand side by the negative but anyway
let's think about which value for d
makes x equals negative 3 a solution for
this
well let's substitute x equals negative
3 here and then we just have to solve
for d if x equals negative 3 is going to
be negative the square root of
3 times negative 3 is negative 9
plus 25
is equal to d
two times negative three is negative six
so d
minus six
and so
now
we can square
both sides of we can square actually
let's do it this way we can i don't want
to square both sides because we lose
some information is going to be the
negative square root of negative 9 plus
25 is 16 is equal to d minus 6. so this
is going to be equal to the neg this is
going to be equal to negative 4.
principle root of 16 is 4 we have the
negative out front is equal to d
minus 6
and then add 6 to both sides you get 2
is equal to
2 is equal to d
so if d is equal to 2 here if d is equal
to 2 then a solution to this purple
equation is going to be x equals
negative 3. and so that would be an
extraneous solution because if x equals
negative 3 satisfies this over here it's
definitely going to satisfy this over
here but it's not going to satisfy this
up here and you can verify this if this
is equal to if this is equal to 2 try
out x equals negative 3. you're going to
get on the left hand side you're going
to get 16
and on the right hand side you're going
to get 2 minus 6
which is equal to
negative 4
2 minus 6 which is negative 4 so this
does not work out x equals negative 3 is
not a solution to this but it is a
solution for this and it is a solution
to this quadratic right over here so d
equals 2 makes x equal negative 3 an
extraneous solution for
this equation